hello welcome back to the GameSpot stage
right here at e3 2014 III is not the
only thing that's on right now oh no I'm
gonna be sitting on not even this stage
they're gonna be sitting on the other
stage when the FIFA World Cup in Brazil
2014 kicks off at Brazil vs. Croatia I'm
very sad that I'll be missing it but I'm
very happy to have leave a producer of
the games Nick Cannon on the stage
pleasure to meet you sir and you thank
you for being here FIFA 15 last year was
niching year for you guys you obviously
were released evey
we can now call past gen version of FIFA
14 and then he also released the
next-gen version which was actually
substant very different yeah to what the
other one was 15 is it in their unified
experience or what are you bringing new
to the I mean I think what we're what we
did last year and what will always
continue to do is we will always drive
innovation on gen 4 in particular yeah
we're still moving forward on the gen 3
consoles making that that'll see
significant improvements this year but
we don't want the technology to be
hamstrung by you know that the old
consoles yeah we're driving the
innovation as much as we can on you know
on Xbox one and PlayStation 4 and
obviously this year we've also announced
that the next-gen version will be also
on PC whereas last yes based on gen 3 so
really trying to drive the innovation I
think a lot of people will be happy
about that I'm assuming that was an
issue with you know I'm just talking to
with this year that you're my my
hat-trick of EA folks for bit of sports
game that is a problem when you're
trying to make games every single year
surely well yeah I mean when you're
making a game for a new console you've
got to make the game whilst also while
the machines are also being made - yeah
you know it's a difficult thing to do we
you know we had a team on it for a
couple of years making sure that that
transition was really strong I think
everyone understands we didn't quite get
it right the last transition so we made
sure that the game was fully featured
all the major features were on there and
then spend time to also innovate for the
new hardware so the base was there and
then obviously now this year we can
bring that same technology to PC and
FIFA 14 for a next-gen was definitely a
strong transition what do you guys doing
with 15 really a lot of stuff this year
so it's given us that great base to
really start to innovate again so you
know a number of things that we're doing
and it is around like the player model
so we've completely
worked all of our player models this
year I don't know if we're gonna see it
on screen but yeah I think that's a
message I got Lionel Messi here just
showing just how athletic he looks he
looks lean he looked toned we felt at
times previously our player model looked
a bit you know that the shirt would look
a bit baggy though in a bit dropped in
the shoulders so spend a lot of time
making sure that that looks great and as
you can see it here just how much more
athletic he looks more toned around the
shoulders and the arms so completely
reworked our player model and also the
animation rig underneath it and the next
thing that we've done is some technology
we were working on for a couple of years
in the background that we're going to be
bringing in so if we see a screenshot
now of the full game we're gonna see a
screenshot of fifa 15 fifa 14 ok as you
see right here it looks a little bit
lemony this looks great we're very proud
of this game it looks like Arsenal I'm
gonna beat Man City as well whether but
you don't see there's no detailing in
the pitch it looks a little bit flat and
then if we transition to the next
screenshot you'll see that's how it 150
oh wow it's a dramatic difference you've
got all this sort of detailing and the
pitch itself and this is using a
technique that we call physically based
rendering as I say been working on that
for a couple of years you can only do it
with the sort of power of the new
consoles so really pleased with that I
don't know you've got a video that shows
the time-lapse of how the the footprints
work but if we bring that up
we're actually simulating the footsteps
of every single player on the pitch not
only do you see footprints you'll see
slide marks or slide tackles we also now
have cloth so when you do that slide
tackle you'll stand see dirt or on the
kits as well so it's also you know it's
bringing the game to life it makes it
look a lot more realistic and authentic
and we think it's a huge step forward
and I you know in our visual quality
yeah cutting up the etihad is always a
fun experience I think I didn't like not
the editing hat I was thinking of the
Emirates Emirates is one of the best bit
pristine as well yeah truly amazing and
so how bad can that stuff get can you
like really caught on pictures like ah
it's different I we just saw a glimpse
at the end there when it goes to rain
you'll see it's more mud than it is so
you know when you when it's a clear day
you get the footprints it's just pushing
the grass down whereas you see you know
when it's wet you'll start to see it
gets a bit more muddy excellence in
terms of the player movements player
control every single year you guys it's
it's almost like a good
problem to have in that you seem to be
that the community seems to generally
have only maybe one or two little
niggles the general control and the head
of players move is fundamentally sound
so ever every year how do you address
what you want to do next because there's
obviously a pressure to do something but
then when it's when the fundamental
basics are working so well how do you
decide what you want to work out well we
look at lots of different elements it's
you know every year we look at the game
and it's okay how can we improve it how
can we make that next leap forward and
like last year we introduced on neck on
the next-gen consoles a step based
locomotion you know it's a dramatic
change in the look and the feel of our
game but we did get some feedback from
our community that it felts at times
unresponsive so we've worked a lot on
that a lot more animation coverage a lot
more agile tight turns and I think you
know people have played it just feel
completely feel the difference this year
I think we've got some the game footage
here where we're going to show a new
technology around some of the emotion I
know one of your favorite players is
Nasri I was going to see here so
actually he's just been fouled by Neymar
okay so in this situation we're actually
monitoring the emotional state of all 22
players on the pitch so Neymar is
probably had a couple of bad challenges
on Nazeri and you can see is reacting to
that so that becomes a reaction but if
we just wind it back we've actually got
Aaron McCarty our league gameplay
producer in the back here in controlling
the game if we wind it back you're
actually going to see in the background
yaya touré puts his arm up and he's
actually appealing for the yellow card
we move it forward you got any esta just
in behind the referee and he knows the
cards coming yeah so all of these
players now are reacting to different
situations if we move it forward he
going to see messy and Jaco Jaco likes
applauds has applauded the decision
Messi doesn't like the decision they
know it's one of his you know Messi
knows it's one of his best players on
his team the players now have a memory
they now have context they understand
what's going on and you'll start to see
not just in these situations but also a
big goal at the end of the game players
will react differently than a goal early
on you know and they'll also you know in
this case bad challenge it might be it
with a great tackle at the game-saving
tackle players will come in and come on
actual 8x so it gives this emotional
state and this intensity I mean I think
you'll agree footballs the most emotive
sport there is and we really wanted to
bring that down on
onto the pitch actually I'm NASA we
didn't cool off if it was a little bit
cooler there maybe he'd be going to the
World Cup with France exactly there you
go guys
so the next thing I think we're going to
show here is is what we're doing and
again this talked about the
responsiveness and the feedback we got
from the community last year it's not
just about the player movement itself
issue I wanted to make the game
responsive in all areas even more
responsive shows in more areas so what
you're seeing here is at new ball
physics in what we call correct context
but also run run touch dribbling we're
there we can now look at the predominant
foot of the player so we all know Messi
is predominantly a foot in you saw every
touch there was inside on the outside of
his left foot yeah but what we're also
doing here is with the ball physics is
the ball physics now are true to exactly
where the ball touches and you'll see
now if you just move it forward the ball
touch is perfect and the spin of the
ball is - and what this means is
previously we were zeroing the spin on
every touch and then re imparting spin
what this does is it looks great but
actually what it really does is the
responsiveness and fluidity in passing
and just gone to another level so really
a huge difference there you know around
passing the ball and as you'll see as we
just finished off here with a shot it
looks really nice as well I have seen
see the grass when you when the
PlayStation 4 version of this came out I
spent a embarrassingly long amount of
time just uploading screenshots aside
from this thing like pretending I was
like it was almost like I was playing
sports photography simulator and just
taking stupid shot like low depth of
field shots behind sheds head yeah of
what it's like well this is what you see
I mean look at the visuals now you've
seen the detail in the grass you see
that the new lighting which makes a
dramatic effect on also how good the
players look as well excellent
so I think if we move onto the next
sequence we're now going to talk about
how we're getting that fluidity in
control and also responsiveness now in
tackling so you're going to see the
michaelis come here and do a slide
tackle and actually just as we paused it
here this is our physics system coming
in as well he actually braces because he
know there's going to be a touch on him
sweat so his arms up he grimaces as he
comes up and as he comes out of this
situation here will actually come up
dribbling and we never had get up
dribbles before so again you lost that
responsiveness and control in that
situation so he gets up and comes out
dribbling
I think and we go to the next situation
this is obviously more common as stand
tackle before we see that here is
another just a volley touch which is
brand new you'll see the the ball
control you'll see the spin on the ball
here but look at now the defender in the
tackle he comes up and the ball stays
close viously the ball you probably know
it gets quite far away from you quite
often goes back to the opposition it
felt unresponsive it was frustrating
this is what we call a possession tackle
so again much more feeling of control
around tackling the ball and then if we
go into the next one this is a new
physics again and control shoulder
challenge here easing the player off the
ball using that body position and then I
think we've got one more coming up now
this is all about a new AI so we want
the AI to feel like much more like we're
playing against each other more
human-like players will now we were
talking about Chelsea earlier the city
are at sea now parking the bus on you
okay no they're actually up you know up
a goal late they want to protect that
lead so they're actually you can see
here ten men completely behind the ball
and Barcelona who we all know go a
little bit more ticky tack of style
later on in the game are actually going
to go more direct so you can see here
NES they actually plays a great ball
into Messi but there's all the systems
coming into play so I'll just show you
here the emotion system Messi makes a
nice run along the line and that's the
points I want the pass here put it in
here for me he comes in it's a great
ball in if we just pull back slightly
you'll see company actually is appealing
for offside that's tight that's a new
volley type obviously nice contact with
the ball and now we have a get up
celebration that we've never had before
he gets up he's got it's a big goal at
the end of the game he's getting up
celebrating city is still appealing for
offside Joe hearts letting a goal gets
up and then he realizes that the the
flags up excellent a slight delay now on
the offside just all those details
exactly he starts to celebrate and then
he turns and realizes oh well no he's
upside so you can see Joe Hart still
thinks he's scored so so yeah this is
brought bringing that emotional feeling
and you know what we really want to do
is these are all the feelings you get
when you're watching the game in TV yeah
we didn't feel we always had that sort
of emotional reaction from
players at times they wouldn't do a lot
again it's bringing that emotional
reaction in you the player that just
adds to your experience what's it like
you're fixing focusing so much on these
details which often times when a player
is playing the game perhaps they realize
it but they don't yet realize they're
saying and I think it's that it's the
entire package and I wouldn't want to
point out that this focus for us is
always gameplay the number one thing our
biggest you know the biggest size of our
team is game play and always will be but
these details just add to that
experience add to that feeling of
authenticity which is so important in
any game so you know it's it's that
balance but for me when you see when you
see the reactions it's what you expect
to see it's what you see on TV it's what
makes you know that the sport that we
love you know that connection for you so
whilst he might not jump out of you that
first minute it then becomes some feels
very natural cool I'm gonna take a
couple of questions for in the community
as well really first one Excalibur Chris
asking dynamic weather obviously yeah
there's always loads of different
weather and FIFA games have you guys
ever tried to play with the idea of
bringing in rain then dries up yeah it's
a great idea we won't have it this year
you know it's not something that we you
know we have the the ability to do right
now but I think it's a great idea and
bunch of questions about modes obviously
the the blast generates the next-gen
version had stuff like online friendlies
and custom tournament and tournament
mode weren't in it are you guys going to
address it this yeah I'm very happy to
say tournament mode back in and so is
guest play so the two major things that
unfortunately we just couldn't get to
yeah as we move to the new consoles are
both back in this year yeah excellent
I'm assuming ultimate team will be
making a return on both for yeah we'll
be talking about Ultimate Team in a lot
more detail with the new things in there
in the next month or so
axel obviously very important mode for
us and might be a bit a little bit
specific that's question I have I
remember the online friendlies in the
next-gen version were only four people
on your friends list are you guys gonna
have match me open matchmaking again so
we do I mean we have the online we have
seasons go which is your completely open
play anyone it's incredibly popular mode
in that game we obviously added the the
promotion and relegation to back in FIFA
12 so that's all there but the
friendlies part is specifically for your
friends you know have that we know
people that you know and then you're
going to play seasons for that to play
anyone in okay
okay fair enough and I think that's a
bunch of questions coming in but I think
we've basically covered everything
especially in showing the new physics
the game as well I mean if one thing I
will say as well is just again the
community feedback is incredibly
important to us we talked a lot about
responsiveness obviously we've got a lot
of feedback in the last year about
headers and three balls yeah overpowered
headers so I will point out that a lot
of the work we're doing in the contacts
with the ball actually hasn't quite a
big effect on those as well so one of
the issues we had with threw balls last
year was at lowest lower pace the error
on the threw balls wasn't as much as
we'd like so we're tuning that but also
the contacts help with that we're tuning
their headers crosses now won't be quite
as powerful because again it's harder to
get a perfect cross because of the way
the ball physics work but we're also
tuning and so we really do listen to the
feedback we're getting we understand it
and obviously we'll be looking at that
for this year I've got one last question
then it's in my ear and I'm only asking
this because we have a FIFA League at
games part and there's one thing that we
realized a couple of weeks ago when
you're doing random games yeah if you
hit random game we do the five random
game hit at five times and then you land
on whatever team you get right we keep
getting the same three to really Spain
Scotland's and some Mexican Premier
League okay and I've put it out on
Twitter and apparently was in Monterey
right Monterey so I know you put it in
on Twitter and people were like oh I
keep getting this this and this
whoever's hidden doing coding that
random thing okay just make it a bit
better look that's great back thank
thank you thank pleasure at FIFA 14 for
next-gen and previous gen what win are
there
15:53 2014 is at the end of September
awesome thanks very much go stage a
really [ __ ]